welcome to some more game analysis by me
Grandmaster Simon Williams I hope you're
all doing all right very sunny over here
in England what a day of chess has been
today and we're looking at the final day
of this semi-final between Hikaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen can Hikaru
beat Magnus finally in a competition and
we're looking at one of the games that
led up to the Armageddon I will give
that much away I won't tell you what
happened in the Armageddon until later
on but in this game Hikaru has the white
pieces and it was something quite
special preparation wise here in this
game so Hikaru starts with evil and
Magnus now plays d5 we go into a rule
Lopez opening with Bishop b5 being
played a 6 Bishop a4 and now Knight to
f6 you may remember that Magnus played
Knight to f6 and moved before in my
previous game at add a video now I've
got nothing against magnets just want to
bear that in mind you know he's a
fantastic champion and you may think
that with my commentary but no no I love
Magnus I love what he's doing for chess
24 this competition being run there as
well just in case any of you haters ask
any questions about that all the chess
company is doing a great job
come on let's pull together and here
white castles and black has a number of
options in this position b5 been the
main role a PEZ but Magnus goes for
Knight takes e4 and this is an old
variation I say old but it's quite a
forcing line because black captures that
porn immediately leading to quite open
positions this featured quite heavily in
Karpov Casper cop of versus Korchnoi let
me get that right
well championship matches and Bobby
Fischer has a lot of experience in this
line on the white side not as commonly
seen but still seeing time and again
and Hikaru now plays b4 of course you
want to open up the center when your
king is canceled and your opponent's
king is not castled here the intention
is to open up that efile black plays b5
bishop be free and now the best move
pawn to d5 black must do something in
the middle of the board one game that
occurred in 1961 where Fischer had the
white pieces continued with pawn takes
d4 very greedy move and is a very nice
line here which you also see in some
variations like the max Liang attack a
typical theme should I say and that is
rook e1 pinning the Knight d5 only move
and now the very nice move Knight to c3
whoa what kind of move is that
well it's aiming to break down the
defense on the ephah by attacking the d5
pawn and if that Knight is taken white
can take on d5 and that is one killer
bishop look at the power of that piece
on that d5 square so black plays d5
which is the main line and now D takes
e5 this poem can be a very useful
attacking point in White's position it
was X well champion alaka'i who said
that if you get a pawn as white to the
e5 square it is a real base to start a
King side attack because it gives you
control on some some squares over there
on the King side and you can sort of
place your pieces behind this borne to
attack but now we have some heavy theory
and the one thing I would say if you're
gonna play this kind of open position I
say open because there's many open lines
you really must know your theory I for
one wouldn't really want to go into this
because the amount of memory I'm too old
for that stuff now my mind my cells are
being destroyed don't ask me why and it
really does require lots of preparation
this is goes this lettuce one of the
players down here Bishop e6 has have to
support this pawn and now Queen e2 a
little bit of pressure on the knight and
so the rook can come into the game
pinning the pawn on d5 applying pressure
to Black's Center Bishop to e7 rook d1
plate and Magnus now gets his King
castled now the idea behind white's play
is to play forcefully and this is
something Hikaru does incredibly well
being such a quick calculates may be the
quickest calculator in the world pawn to
c4 aiming to destroy that central
position and the knight here can often
be quite weak because in a lot of cases
it's very fragile especially if white
can break down this pawn on d5 which is
holding that night in the central square
you see this kind of theme in many a for
openings B takes c4 Bishop takes c4 that
pawn is pinned so it can't be moved
because of the Queen on d8 Bishop c5
starting a counter-attack against f2 I
will tell you when we deviate from
previous encounters previous games white
develops and stops at fret and now black
exchanges on e3 and now place Queen b8
a rather forcing idea this removes the
Queen from the pin and starts and play
against b2 and now white must do
something with this Bishop because it's
gonna be hanging in a lot of lights so
be sure to be free and now Knight to a5
aiming for that Bishop Hikaru takes a
very nice square in the center of the
board having a knight in the center like
that can be very good but in this moment
it's not going to remain there for long
because of c5 kicking it away another
forcing move Knight takes c6 and here
Magnus thoughts and attack against f2
but this is all being seen before move
17 here every again forcing the pace
it's one of those games where if you
know your stuff and your memory holds up
you should be okay Magnus should be
alright as black but I think he cut
Cara's opening choice is very clever
because black may be able to equalize
but only if you
plays absolutely perfectly and remembers
all this theory and even the world
champion magnus carlsen struggles to do
this Magnus having one of the most
amazing the memories in chess he is a
bit of a bit of a genius when it comes
to memory and chess as we know but here
it actually lets him down
he plays c4 black again has to
counter-attack there's no time to move
backwards in the position and white
captures on e4 black captures on be free
a very complex position white is trying
to say that his Center will cause black
a number of difficulties for example he
now captures on d5 and these two pawns
do look very strong especially with a
queen supporting them and a rook on the
other hand White's pieces here are not
developed on the Queen side
he needs to get them in the game to be
effective and black's pawn over here is
a bit of a nuisance look at that pawn Go
Go Go Go Johnny Go Go Go Johnny be good
and it takes out on a to this pawn has
to be removed rook takes a two and now
the knight moves away from the side of
the board where it's weak into a much
more active position attacking the Queen
and again this is all pretty forced
Queen to the forum now black can't
capture the pawn on d5 because if he
does he runs into a very nasty check and
the knight is no longer stable on c4 so
he doesn't really again have much choice
here the knight has no we're good
to retreat to or move into so he has to
move forwards activating the Queen
attacking the rook and defending the
knight hikaru now develops his last last
piece Knight to c3 defending the rooks
and this is the key moment this position
had been seen previously in 2018 between
two elite grandmasters Wei Yi of China
and vidit and up-and-coming real
talented player from India you may have
watched some of his streams he's getting
a lot of people on his streams and for
good reason don't check him out and he
Vivat in his game played rook on a to c8
Magnus now deviates in place the first
novelty Knight takes b2 but in actual
fact this turns out to be a very big
error not clear to see unless you've
analyzed the game beforehand the correct
way to approach this position let's
remember you have to you have to get up
to this bar maybe 20 free moves and you
probably have to remember the next seven
in order to be safe is rug to c8 and
here black simply gets another piece in
the game so when he plays Knight takes
b2 this would be much stronger because
of pressure against c3 rook to be one
happened in way Yi and after Knight to
d2 Queen takes d2 again very forcing
rook takes c3 getting rid of that night
so the rook on a2 is now able to be
captured Queen takes a - lots of pieces
get exchanged and after some more
exchanges here we can see that the
position is petering out into a rook and
pawn ending which will be a draw with
careful play the black rook can activate
and this is a theoretical draw some care
may be needed from black but at this
level there's not enough pieces on the
board for either side to win so I just
believe Magnus may be felt a little bit
of pressure and forgot what he was doing
it happens to all of us maybe reinsuring
to see that even the best player in the
world
sometimes just forgets that one move and
after Knight takes b2 he can replace
amazing chess really on fire today is
great to see him you know come back from
0 out of free on the first day to then
win the second date and get into a
position on this final day in the
semi-finals two fights show real real
character that's what you need to get to
the top in any sport
rooks b1 now played and we're gonna see
here that Queen c4 is the only way black
can save his Knight but after the
capture on c4 and now capturing e6
white is a porn up but most importantly
this eport creates numerous tactical
problems for black as with shortly sea
routes where five to try to get the rug
behind that porn normally the best place
for a rook in an ending is behind your
opponent's past porn so if you get to
rook and portending try to put that to
practice your results will improve and
now here car replays very actively
Knight to d5 again brilliant play this
night dives into the game and there's a
beautiful tactical idea now the main
threat is Knight to e7 so Magnus
continues with his idea and here rook
takes a six boom what a beauty and this
move is possible because of the back
rank the pawn on e6 takes away the f7
square for the black King so if this
rook is taken we have a typical case of
a weak back rank and Weissberg can slide
down elegantly onto the BH square
delivering checkmate so a really
beautiful idea now to also gain a tempo
and hang on to that extra pawn rook to
e8 has to be tried and if Magnus can
just win this one pawn it will be a draw
but it's Hikaru to move and he keeps the
pressure up he knows that if he gives
Magnus a chance to consolidate it will
only be a draw
Knight to c7 attacking the rook
defending the pawn on e6 and now the
final mistake by Magnus rook to d8 the
only drawing chance here was actually to
play rook to c8 again trying to at some
point attack this Knight probably age
six will have to be played next so the
King has an escape square but keeping
some pressure on the position and now
one line I was analyzing continued with
something bizarre like roots of b5
trying to get rid of that strong rook
the rook gives a check luckily the White
King has f2 as an escape square we can
see why this pawn is very useful
doesn't have a counterpart on e3 and now
if rook to e4 Knight to d5 trying to
reroute again
but after route to f8 check King g3
Knight to b3 black is starting to
coordinate his army it still looks very
dangerous but now the white king is also
in some problems one idea is Knight to
f5 and route to h4 checkmate so had you
know Hikaru blundered now with this
movie se7en Knight to f5 check is
turning the tables completely but of
course Hikaru wouldn't do that
so magnets plays rook to d8 can you see
the amazing idea a second route to c6
first trying to force this night away
this night is quite actively placed and
it defends some key squares the knight
now has to move and what is the
beautiful move again exploiting the back
rank of Magnus Carlsen in this position
it's only one move really which gives he
karu the win and it is rook to d6
beautiful stuff and this can't be taken
because of rook b8 and the point is
after rook c8 now this rook gets to a
very useful square a rook on the 7th
frank is very powerful and a 6 is coming
and after h 6 e 67 king h7 rook to e1
magnus resigned because this pawn is
gonna Queen black will have to give his
rook up for this let's just demonstrate
this there's not many good moves here at
all for black let's say he tries King g6
trying to get the King around somewhere
well one kind of easy way to do this is
the Queen Black has to capture here and
in this position we now have rook to de
fries and again this is exploiting a pin
in the position this time the pin on the
e-file to win a piece fantastic game
from a car of his accuracy was 99.5%
that is unheard of nowadays in chess I
wonder how much of it was preparation on
his part but
you still have to remember it even if it
is preparation he calculated well played
of aggression Magnus slipped up there at
one moment he did come back in typical
Magnus fashion to win the next game
bringing it to Armageddon where you
default Magnus maybe favorites but
Hikaru kept his nerve Magnus even
blundered and Hikaru goes through to the
final so congratulations to he Kaoru for
a brilliant victory he must be extremely
happy with that unlucky two Magnus but
as Magnus tweeted he will be back like
the video subscribe to chess comm and
there's gonna be so much more good chess
with everything going on online at the
moment we're in for many more treats
good bye for now